yeah hey david it's sarah from mass  again i hate to be calling again like  this but you're a liar again  uh kaylee mcinerney never lied um the  cdc she never lied  he has since adjusted the numbers the  numbers have been adjusted  six percent of the numbers is what the  real cases are yep the  real so for every million cases that are  reported only six percent of those are  true guys  and it is and they also said it's just  the common cause  that's what they said check this it's  the common cold my friends that's it  cdc website but you don't want to do  that do you and also with the audits  they're figuring out yeah there were a  lot of illegal votes  so it was the real life a lotter illegal  votes  a lotter illegal votes guys liar  project much eric from maps  really really powerful message there